e4 and we've been playing the karo khan
but
this time let's play the alakan i've
heard some rumblings about the alakan
we'll play the alkene it's positional
enough where
it passes the test
okay knight knight c3 now
the proper alakin-esque way to play here
is not e5 but transpose into the vienna
you could do that
expected 11 but actually d5 so you might
be like but isn't this the scandi well
it's a really good scandi
because if white trades everything on d5
you no longer will have a b1 night
to put on c3 so it's an improved version
this equalizes
e5 okay that's the main line here
you know you kind of have to have
experience in this line to know what to
do
because otherwise your instinct is to
move the knight which is fine
but the best move here is what who knows
what black can play here
it's actually to counter attack white's
knight with d4 yeah
yeah counter attacking white side that
is the cleanest path to equality here
and this leads to sort of mutually
assured destruction takes takes
and then if you continue calculating
you'll see the black intake on d2 with
check
and that check is what allows black to
survive the
mutual destruction of forces
yeah there's no four queens like taking
on g7 taking on b2 doesn't make sense
because white's gonna make a queen and
then he's gonna capture the queen on a1
but there are some four queen lines
that's that does happen in some other
openings
okay f takes e7 again
um he's playing this very well uh so c
takes the two check
then we capture and he said it's equal
all right it's it's a completely equal
position it's symmetrical pawn structure
if you think about it
he takes with the queen then we should
go into the end game let's see what he
does
yeah it's a nice line
okay
yeah i mean if you're attuned to these
kinds of ideas then
it'll be natural so here i think some of
you might be attracted to
possibility of taking upon with check
but you know what i always say
this is one of the refrains from the
early part of the spirit it's like
making moves just because they pose a
threat or are delivered with check which
is essentially the same thing
that is a source of many mistakes
because that should not in and of itself
be a reason for playing the move there
has to be a secondary reason and queen
takes c7 is actually very detrimental
to black's position can somebody explain
to me why that is why should we go into
the end game why is queen take c7 risky
like why can't we well we can play it
it's fine it's not great it blocks the
bishop
but you might be like what hasn't white
blocked his bishop well
it's not symmetrical white's gonna have
a much easier time castling short
black is gonna have a very hard time
castling short and that's a problem
because
your king might get caught in the
crossfire does that make sense
so you can play bishop e7 here but
the most clinical is just to take the
queen and then play bishop take c7
yeah exactly now we'll recapture we'll
recapture by developing
all right takes so dead equal very well
played
castles is great he's playing this super
well
and well we shouldn't reinvent the wheel
here we we castle this is what i would
call a queenless middle game
it's you know two rooks and three pieces
versus two rooks and three pieces
it's not quite an end game yet knight f3
is good
what should we do now how should we how
should we develop and one of the key
principles for queenless positions right
is the absence of principles you often
shouldn't change the way that you play
just because queens are off the same
rules apply development act
active development good positioning of
pieces
and knight c6 is fine but the small
subtle thing i would notice here knight
c6 bishop b5
is a little bit annoying right a little
bit annoying he might take the knight
and here's the other important rule pawn
structure becomes a lot more important
when the queens are off the board
very important you know that i
de-emphasize pawn structure
with the queens off the board pawn
structure on all sides of the board
becomes important because of course you
get a greater probability of eventual
transition to a pawn end game
so i would propose um
to do the same thing to widen go bishop
g4
right so i would play bishop g4 first
keep this knight on b8 for now maybe
we'll put it on d7
or maybe white will go here which is
quite likely that's what
somebody you know this rating might be
thinking and it's not a bad move it
should work
it's a great move though okay so
he is attacking the pawn but as with the
middle game
you can go do you automatically react to
every threat that you are faced with
not necessarily right sometimes you do
sometimes you sacrifice stuff
for initiative and you can do the same
thing in the end game it's harder to
pull that off
so i after the game will explain a move
such as knight c6 that would be a very
interesting move
but in this game in this uh with black
we're trying to play very solidly
so let's for the purposes of solid play
let's defend the pawn of c6
that takes away the square from the
knight but that's okay because the
knight has d7 as a perfectly legitimate
development square
and it's not that essential to put it on
c6 here
h3 this guy is playing very well so h3
is good
now there is a bit of an issue with
taking the knight on f3
that issue is that it takes away a
defender from the d7 squad making it
very difficult
for us to develop the knight then to d7
so
we need to preserve the bishop because
that is the sort of conduit that
allows the knight to get out we don't
want our queen side to be undeveloped so
where should we put this bishop
i actually propose a pretty radical move
here
because the issue with putting it on e6
that's the natural square
is that in the same issue with bishop f5
by the way
white can bother that bishop by
centralizing his knight 94.
if we put the bishop on d7 we take that
square away from the knight we also
blunder the bishop
because he can take the knight so we are
going to go bishop ca
i know that that it's not an easy move
to play we're slightly worse here he's
playing this super well but sometimes
you have to make these kinds of
damage control moves right because that
allows us to develop the night watch
what happens
knight d7 then we're going to get the
knight onto a civilized square and then
we're going to reopen
uh you know we're going to reopen the
businesses we're going to get the bishop
out
so i know that this looks really weird
but that's the luxury
of this kind of position because it's an
end game or a queenless middle game
the there is there isn't the same
immediacy right you can
take a long a longer time developing
your pieces and in doing so ensure that
you're not getting harassed by your
opponent
okay
now i'm not telling you that you should
always retreat a piece back to its
initial square those moves can be very
damaging
but i think you can see the logic here
and i'll explain this in greater detail
after the game
all right this is a pretty instructive
moment and we were worse after bishop c
i think g4 was not a good move by him
though
yeah well that night's blocking the
bishop
yeah well we'll we'll discuss that
already beer
yeah again the specific line i can't
make moves during the game
so i know you're into it and he's
disconnected unfortunately
but i promise i'll explain this stuff
after the game thank you for the 100
bits
no no pin the elder oh you're obsessed
with being with pinning
but i'll explain that too
and that is the same reason why we
didn't take the night
yeah he's disconnected he's about to
lose on time in 10 seconds jeremy fish
think of the prime thank you everybody
for the support
i really appreciate everybody who subs
and supports by engaging
all of the subs really really help i
always appreciate it thank you guys and
another one sir 289 unfortunately he is
disconnected yeah that
that really sucks because he was playing
an excellent game
okay so
still we have a very instructive mom to
talk about he's slightly better in this
position
he's slightly better in this position
yeah so
i agree with you probably bishop e6
would have been better here but i wanted
to really
show the moment there
okay so one moment please
yeah now alakine d5 e5 d4
that is one of the downsides of the
alkyne is there is this lackluster
end game that occurs but this end game
can occur in a different way here
this is also a line takes takes takes
you get a similar position this time
bishop is fianchetto
also a little bit of a boring end game
but
here's what i want to make very clear
those of you who are really ambitious
want to get good
you have to know how to play these kinds
of positions you cannot entirely avoid
boring positions nor should you try to
you can at a very
like a beginner level but eventually you
get into a position where
no matter how sharp your opening
repertoire there are boring lines
against everything
and with black then you can face the
london system
so embracing these positions and
detecting the subtleties within them
there is a certain kind of beauty to
that and uh
obviously i find these end games to be
as distasteful as most people
but i've sort of trained myself to
appreciate
the subtleties in them embrace the
enwing
um so take stakes take stakes
castles castles knight f3 and bishop g4
i can yeah i can second that course by
brian he's a good friend of mine he's
awesome i mean he's nnm so you might bat
an eye at that you know why isn't he a
gm he's a
huge alkyne specialist and he knows how
to analyze
um okay so bishop g4 vision f4 and
really the key moment was here
all right now first of all we could have
sacrificed upon in a real game i would
have played knight c6
and if bishop takes c7 i would have
considered something like rook c8 and
then
knight before and we get a pretty big
initiative in return for
the pawn but that was something to
consider we played c6
now the key position right
so first of all bishop h5 is the really
the instinctual answer
what's the issue with bishop h5 and this
it's exactly the same as the issue
with bishop takes f3 who can explain
that to me
and it's simpler than some of you may be
making this out to be
now yes you ruined white swan structure
here you can't move the knife that's a
disaster that is a disastrous thing
because your entire queen side and the
train car has gotten disattached from
the train
white can finish his development and
start harassing you down the center
can't you pop the thing with the tier
one you can't develop the knight if you
go knight a6 you allow rift e7
with a crushing fork if you try to go
rook d
a trying to that's probably the best
move that doesn't help why can go bishop
c4
and still you can't develop the knight
because if you
look at this very carefully you will
notice the rook defends the knight
and this rook can be attacked with
bishop c7
winning material so that's the issue
with these two moves so we have to keep
the bishop on this diagonal if bishop b6
according to the computer this was
better than what i did the move that
bothered me is knight to d4
harassing the bishop threatening to
capture it and ruin black structure and
again make it impossible for the knight
to develop
um and rdber suggested bishop d5 but the
bishop is not stable here
we've talked about this in the previous
game
this might look very solid
but it's not stable because of
because of the simple c4 yeah and if you
go bishop e4
boom boom undefended undefended simple
pin rookie one
so you have to go back to e6 that's not
that bad
you could argue that well you've gotten
the pawn to move out to c4
making it harder for the bishop to
develop i think you guys can all see
that
this is not a very desirable situation
again you can't really develop the
knight
so that was my rationale here because
behind playing bishop ca
because what i thought was well he can't
really stop me now from developing
tonight
i'm going to get the knight to b6 or f6
and then we're going to re-develop the
bishop which is much easier to develop
than the knight there's more options
however had he played bishop c4
i might not have had the time to do what
i wanted to do and i actually kind of
missed this because
97 he gets his rook out you can see how
active white's pieces are here still
it's very solid for black
it's actually hard to make something
happen here but this is not a fun
position at all
nevertheless we can get the night out
then we get the bishop out and we slowly
try to neutralize the initiative chess
is a hard game
but hopefully you were able to trace the
logic here
yeah we could have gone c5 but i don't
like that move that's
very weakening although i see what
you're saying you want to you want to
preserve the c6 square right
i like it from that perspective but it
creates that weakness on d5 you see what
i'm saying it's like
it creates a lot of holes in the
position so
i thought this was the lesser evil to go
c6
all right yeah the simple nuances
take the cake here and that
those nuances are not based in some sort
of crazy
concepts that nobody knows it's a matter
of combining logic that can be hard to
sort of
understand initially all right let's
do one more i feel like i i should
you know the support is awesome so i'm
feeling i'm feeling one last game
is there a particular reason you opted
into the queen trait are there any other
decent lines out of the opening
no worries um no i do like focusing
that's a great question
uh yes so you can play e5 and transpose
into a vienna
you'd have to know those lines they'll
be on a gambit or a four knights defense
or um you could also
refrain from d4 think of ed that could
come in
in various forms you can play knight fd7
this transposes potentially to a french
two knights
or the smooth e6 that is a very
dangerous pawn sacrifice that's why i
didn't do it
you could also go 94 as far as i know
94 is okay but this gets a little bit
risky this pawn is weak so you could
investigate this
i don't know where the current theory
stands in this i do know d4 is the most
reputable move
but you could definitely conduct your
investigations and certainly you could
uh get decent positions against
your opponent you're not playing magnus
carlsen here
all right guys um
let's continue and we have another black
gaming savage stone
and uh why don't we play another alakan
let's hope he doesn't go knight c3 let's
hope he goes e5
paid to win another gifted two thiagino
89 thank you
and he plays e5 nice so of course knight
d5 that's the that's the idea
the ultimate hyper modern opening
literally the epitome
of hyper modern openings the alakin
where you literally say i'm going to
not sell my pieces for like four moves
and try to get you to overextend your
center
okay so that's a move it's not the best
move we'll talk about the theory
afterward
uh but it does attack the knight and
this knight in the alakan often belongs
on what square
knight to b6 yeah
and the bishop has to move back so he
kind of loses the tempo there
and after the bishop moves back that
that's when we press on the gas pedal
right we don't want to
okay this should be two that's a little
bit passive
and our strategy doesn't really change
we have this pawn on e5
one of the elements of hyper modern
openings is that when your opponent
overextends the center you can use
the pawns as hooks helping you
to contest the central control and you
know
at the same time develop your pieces so
knight c6 is possible here but the most
accurate move is what thank you mule
fish
you should play either d5 here or the
more thematic moves to play d6
immediately saying i want to get rid of
this pawn
if i do get rid of this pawn then white
has really no central control there's no
reason why it is better
i'll talk about knight c6 after the game
okay he goes d4 dude he's credit he's
trying to fight for the center
um but now knight c6
makes more sense because in combination
with moving the pawn we talked about
this don't let your pieces get trampled
on by your opponent's pawns
the way you prevent that is by combining
piece moves and pawn moves making sure
that the pawns act as the kind of
anchors
right that stop your opponent's pawns
from progressing so if knight c6
d5 is that a problem before we play
knight c6 let's figure that one out
is d5 a problem there look at that
position very carefully
it is not because that loses control of
e5 and
drops upon boom he can take and play d5
but that is no longer that is
also not a big problem for the same
reason knight f3 instead
now we need to transform the position
what should we do and the obvious move
is bishop g4 and there's nothing wrong
with it
but in the in the sort of spirit of
positional chess
we should take this opportunity to take
on e5 and go into an end game
and the point is not to go into an end
game the point is that after he takes
for the pawn
if they take on the knight then knight
takes d4 wins upon him but if he takes
the pawn and he does
we we take the queen and this pawn on e5
becomes a huge weakness
so now we see the whole point behind
openings like the alakan well he's one
of the ideas
that the center is overextended he has
more central control than we do but he's
going to probably end up losing this
pawn
or he's going to have to ruin his pieces
in order to preserve the pawn
what should we do how do we put pressure
on this pawn
well what's defending it right in the
night can we pressure the knight
first we should go bishop g4 we
shouldn't go e6 that would be passive
it would lock the bishop behind the
pawns
boom later we'll go e6 okay
very important moment do not just grab
on f3 and grab on e5
why is that bad and what should we do to
remedy that
because it drops the pawn on b7 i'll
tell you what even if it didn't
i wouldn't be so sure that giving up
this bishop on g4
is such a great idea even if it meant
winning the pawn the torture
of and that's where the threat is
stronger than the execution comes from
the fact
that he has to constantly deal with this
pawn being weak
uh can often be a more effective
strategy than actually just winning the
pawn
and then letting him uh really relieving
him of this of his duty so instead we
should castle along
defending the pawn on b7 putting
pressure on the bishop thereby
mobilizing the knight so
now we are threatening to take on f3 we
probably will given the opportunity
but we could also consider just
continuing the pressure with e6
okay
he's probably gonna go bishop f4 but
we'll see
i guess that he i think that he will
recognize the problem here
and if he goes bishop f4 then then we'll
play e6 just developing
he's thinking he recognizes the issue i
think
yeah these are tough tough okay 92 yeah
so so that's
that sort of panic right 500 thank you
so much msd5 510. so what do we do
yeah knight g5 would have dropped the
bishop because there were there are two
different two attackers on it
yeah so we win the fun let's take the
bishop for it we could even take on e5
but
why travel to g4 when you can avoid it
let's just take
and also this puts the white rook in a
pin
okay now i'm taking a second just making
sure that moves like these might even be
stronger but
he can get his knight out to a3 and
defend so let's take the bond instead
but notice that i took a second there to
check and now we we just need to play e6
we need to get our bishop out
yeah and he is yeah 94 that's a good
move
untangling now we could take the rook
it's not it doesn't really matter um we
could also just develop our bishop i
like the concept of just developing
most of the time um this concept
that i call trading on your own terms
forces your opponent into
making these uncomfortable decisions
yeah so bishop
well bishop c5 blunt is the bishop
bishop b4
would be good in different circumstances
but here the knight is defended by the
other knight so he could just chase the
bishop with a3
so in this particular situation the
point of getting the bishop out
is more to connect the rooks than
anything else so
i've made this point before on the
five-minute speed run it is okay
um you know as i've said a million times
that not all of your pieces are climbing
mount everest at every moment
the bishop v7 is fine it restricts the
e49 controls g5 and a thousand minutes
from pin the elder thank you so much
i appreciate that love the support
okay so it also controls the d8 square
which would help us in the amount of a
trade
web 4 is fine he attacks our knight
where should the knight go
we can make a move with tempo here so
one possibility is knight c4 that's
that's interesting
but i like in these alakine kg alakine
spirit going night this sets a trap
if he goes bishop g3 he loses a piece
that is very likely it's very likely
that he does that
he also might go here but no bishop e3
okay he sees it
that doesn't exactly bring him a lot of
relief but we can still try that same
thing
so that night on e4 it's almost been a
a recurring theme today pieces being in
the center but still being susceptible
to getting trampled over by pawns so
knight c4 is a great move
but we could try to go straight for the
straight for the kill here with f5
attacking the knight
and you will see that the knight doesn't
have too many good squares there's no
these two squares put the knight in
contact with the bishop on e7 which we
put there for a reason
and the only piece defending that knight
is the bishop that would be a type 2
undefended piece
those are very vulnerable and if he goes
there we will find a way to dislodge the
bishop from e3
but if he goes knight d2 then he makes
his position even more passive
and that's a pretty big win for us
okay he takes
that's great we'll take
yeah knight c5 so
i will say that he found a very creative
solution
here so yeah so he
what he does is he attacks c6 if we go
f4
he might play knight takes e6
counter-attacking our rook
so unfortunately we need to calculate
some variations here
f4 knight takes c6 we take his bishop
he takes our rook what should we do in
that position
should we take the knight immediately do
we have any intermediate moves
yeah we do have an intermediate move
bishop c5 is interesting but you can
just play e takes f2 check
dispensing with the pawn and then taking
his knight we have
a bishop and a knight for the rook
that's a pretty big advantage for black
because he doesn't have any pawns for it
but i've previously shared with you guys
the idea that
when you've got a two pieces for a rook
scenario when there's no
other pair of rocks on the board that
usually favors the side with the rook
but in this particular instance the
minor pieces are super active
so we are actually going to go for it
and
also the reason i want to go for it is
to show you guys how to play
with such a material imbalance which is
actually super common
so even if this is not what i would have
done in a real game i still feel like
it's worth worthwhile
yeah so he takes kudos star upon he's
playing
very very well
he's playing very well
he might be worried about this pawn so
he might take on e3 i don't know we'll
see
yeah so he he does he takes
so now if we want to be extra accurate
you know if we want to really
be surgical in our position what should
we do
and i've i'm wrong but i still want to
do this
improve the position of the bishop if he
treats the swell
this is actually not as good as it looks
but again i want to show you guys the
principle you're always
on the hunt for intermediate moves which
can come in two different forms
intermediate moves can be tactical but
they can also be positional like
improving the position of the bishop and
then taking the knight
okay so the king should go up to e7 of
course there's no other good square
he made a small error by bringing his
king backward that's not what you should
do in the end game
that's not really a pointless joke he
trades the knights okay fair enough
we have a great i love that we have this
imbalance right with bishop and knight
against rook
with equal pawns first of all he's
attacking the bishop let's drop it back
in order to
attack the pawn in these kinds of
situations peace activity
decides everything absolutely every
the result of the game is decided by the
side that is able to activate their
piece or pieces
with greater efficiency now that is a
laundry
gives us a free pawn and maybe he's
relying on rock h5 in which case we have
a very sexy idea
we have a very sexy idea if he finds
rook h5
which would fork the bishop and the pawn
i think he will find this
and what's that sexy idea how do i even
find this well
when the rook is in a corner like this
right you
often rooks are they seem to be
invincible
but it's not knight f4 that blunders
their bishop no matter the bishop
but it is bishop f4 the thing with the
rooks is that they
they can be trapped you know your rook
can get trapped
by minor pieces in the right set of
circumstances
yeah bishop h6 rook is trapped this is
covered by the knight
team effort h file is covered by the
bishop and the trapping will be done by
the king
which will walk to g8 he can try to put
ram this pawn up the board but he
doesn't have enough time
and that's jail and that's death row
that's it
we're walking into gia don't free move
it because he might take the night boom
it's this is a brutal idea brutal idea
yep yeah that's that's just
that's one of those painful things that
catch you out of the blue
all right it's over he's got to take the
bishop
this guy is playing really well um but
now it's over
we're up a full night let's go 95 check
just win the pawn
bring the knight back and then there's
many ways to win this position
all right he's probably gonna go here
let's bring the king up the simplest is
we're going to bring the king either up
here
yeah so he just gives us access to this
pawn and then we're going to just push
the h1
had i yeah had he gotten here i would
have just created a passport and
distracted his king
yeah resigns great game um amy stone
okay so
let's take a quick look before i head to
bed
that's the allocator bishop c4 is
sub-optimal
um the main line is d4 then black plays
d6 and white plays c4
and you get this kind of position black
intake with either pawn
um cd is the more adventurous move and
this is something i'm going to talk
about later i just i'm kind of tired
right now and i'll
we'll play the alakan a lot more and
we'll discuss the intricacies of the
main line
eva gifting up 10 subs to the community
the 4 a.m
that's what we're talking about thank
you eva appreciate it so
much support evacs toffee
damn girl let's go
loving it loving it thank you okay
so i can in the meantime recommend brian
until this is chestable course it is
phenomenal
the alakan is a great weapon if you're
in the 16 1700 range you want to spice
up your repertoire
both positional and tactical alakana is
great as is
evacs okay knight b6 bishop bishop b2
passive he should have gone b3
and now d6 now don't overthink this move
we're simply trying to get rid of the e5
pawn
control some of the center and open up
our bishop right that's just a
developing move
d4 stubborn knight c6 now we could have
started with knight c6
but this in here played in this
transposes
what we don't want to do right just play
with like e6 this is where it's very
easy to slip into
passivity now our bishop is very unhappy
thank you tom hawker and we're letting
white
essentially trample over us in the
center here white builds up this
this triangle and uh we're very passive
here so the downside of openings like
the alkyne is if you don't know how to
play them well
you will constantly and maybe some of
you guys have experienced this
you'll constantly get run out of the gym
you'll slip into very passive positions
and you'll be miserable so it's
very it's like two polar opposites
either and there's people who are very
passionate about the aloha they love it
um but then there are people who try and
they're like this sucks right
that's the problem with these kinds of
openings well
uh big ol schwifty i think you're
thinking of it the wrong way
i think you shouldn't think of d6 as
some sort of special move
it's just controls some of the center it
opens the bishop like that's a typical
developing move it's commonly played in
all openings
all right so d64 knight c6 knight f3
now we decide to take on e5 we trade
queens
and he should have at this point taken
on d6 and then got c4 which sort of
resembles the main line
tempo up for us and then we fianchetto
this bishop
but okay knight of three boom boom boom
boom boom bishop g4
yeah he should have gone bishop f4
probably either here or here
knight f2 was just way too passive and
after bishop f4
we would go e6 and maybe get this bishop
out maybe bring the knight to d5
white is just very uncomfortable because
this spot is a permanent weakness it's
sticking out like a sore thumb
it's weakening a lot of these squares
and black is slightly better
okay so if there are any questions here
feel free
so here he gives us the pawn and
e6 knight e4 bishop e7 covering these
squares developing the bishop
bishop f4 knight g6 and there was one
little issue thinking noob oh here's a
hype train 1238
tier one knight c might support knight
b5 and i was looking at these kinds of
lines this actually checkmate we would
have got c6 here but i felt like this
was a little unpleasant and another sub
three mt zero and a hundred bits by
music i see what you guys are trying to
do
all right so instead we decided to go
knight to six active retrieving of
bishop e3
had he gone bishop g3 as i i hinted
boom and boom and the bishop is trapped
this is very simple kenji papa sub and
ryan ellis void a sub
what is going on here ladies and
gentlemen thank you guys
yeah so that's just completely winning
so he goes bishop e3
and go off five and
you know i explained this during the
game right we're trying to dislodge the
knight from
e4 and it is no good place to go music
by jm gift in a sub two
etho thori all right takes
takes knight c5 how do you gone knight
c5 immediately
that would have been very inaccurate who
can explain to me why
this move is less accurate than what he
did
curious up to trans tabla oh my god
5 000 bits from me max tuffy
what is this who is this 200 hamichiko
oh my lands that is crazy thank you you
asked you
are insane
smashing level two
yeah so who can figure this out before i
was rudely distracted by that chair
thanks evac i appreciate it
music with 100 bits yeah so the problem
is if we play f4 here guys
that's the same thing as in the game
right boom boom boom if that transposes
but where does this take its power this
takes its power from the fact
that the knight attacks the rook right
otherwise this would just be a pawn and
we would capture the bishop
so yeah oh drama oh drama law god said
very nice we would take on d1 here
sneaky piece of 100
and then we would play f4 and you might
look at this and say
why are we giving up the open file well
that's not the point tactics always
trumps these general considerations
bishop d4 e5 the bishop is trapped and
if the bishop moves back then we take
the knight of knight takes c6 then we
just take the bishop
you see what i'm saying so it was
actually a very good decision for him to
take the rook first knight c5
and that forces us to win this position
oh my god zoidbarf with another 10
gifted subs
what is going on here ladies and
gentlemen this is ridiculous another 10
gifted
wow now this is getting crazy i got to
disable the alerts now because this was
going on youtube
thank you zoidbarf i really appreciate
it
that's this is crazy okay so bishop c5
check and hoax thank you for the tier
one
now oh thank you now he went backwards
f1 which is fine but
i probably should have gone forward to
f3 and knight
king takes d so here he sort of
collapsed now that he decided to trade
the knights which was not particularly
good this knight on c3 should have gone
to e4 that's the reason why this bishop
on c5 is
actually kind of a sitting duck thank
you rahim gunner 49
and we would have dropped the bishop
back and you know the end game would
have gone up
but instead rook d1 check knight d5
check takes takes
and bishop back to d6 so here he makes
the decisive mistake
giving up the pawn c4 is a good thought
he should have played h3
how would we have proceeded in this kind
of position like what is what do we even
think about what do we do
that's what i think overwhelms people
about these types of end games it's not
just not clear
how to manage the pieces here what's
even the plan
and that's entirely the point there is
no clear plan here
um and it's not like you don't know
something about the position all you
should be focusing on here is just
marginally improving the pieces pushing
pawns
carefully to grab space but not doing it
in a way that weakens them so i would
start with king e6
it's not signs here there's many good
moves then i would maybe centralize the
knight you see what i'm doing
then let's say that we're trying to go
to c4 with a fork let's see the y goes
b3 for example
now i would say well that creates some
weaknesses on the queen's head that's
where we want to try to
attack with our minor pieces so one
option here is to
consider what who can propose a move
here like what should we do
so one plan that already clarifies is to
push
the pawns on the queen side but in a
particular kind of way let's start with
a5
our plan is and this is called fixing
the weakness
let's say that white puts up no
resistance to the plan
you know whatever we're going to make
random moves our ultimate
target position is this a pawn on a3
this pawn is anchored by the bishop it's
untouchable nothing is going to happen
to the spawn
even in the event of a freaking
apocalypse it's going to be there
and this pawn on a2 on the other hand is
very weak
if we win that pawn this pawn on a3
might become a queen
and now our plan is to get this knight
to what square to either
aware not the bishop to b4 yeah but the
knight to b4 and the knight to c3 and
that's going to be possible through this
maneuver
so what's going to happen is white is
going to have to tie down the rook to
the defense of the pawn and then we're
going to use our pieces
so you guys can see sort of the general
gist of this
you never win these positions fast you
need to do it step by step
and you need to do it in a way that
in a very careful way you don't want to
create weaknesses right
so that would be one idea or another
idea would be to go
knight c6 and knight before immediately
try to get white spawns to go forward
and then weaken them
stuff like that okay so
i don't want to talk too much about this
i know it's these are tough concepts so
c4 bishop h2 and now we win another pawn
this game is basically over
he can refrain from taking the pawn but
that's pretty vast material advantage
and once he takes it you go bishop h6
and you trap the rook
so that's a very nice pattern
and then we bring the king in and win
the game so he took the bait i mean at
this point there's
very little that can be done create
weaknesses and isolate them yeah
improving the activity of your pieces
and of course past pawns and symmetrical
pawn structures
um and i have a game to finish with i
won't play another one guys it is very
late i'm commentating tomorrow at
noon eastern with robert i've got a lot
of things to do before then
but i do have one game to show you
on the topic of end game planning and
clearing
creating and fixing weaknesses so here
is a good game on the topic
okay um this is from 2007 this is my
my chest career and this was a pretty
this is a game this is a transformative
game for me because
the plan that i applied in this game i
was like girl i actually can do this
kind of stuff
which i had seen in like grand master
games and i heard fixing the weakness
and my eyes were glazed around fixing
the weakness that's something like
karpov does right
but it's it's not rocket science and i
convinced myself of that with this next
game one sec
so this was california state
championship
k-12 2007 i was in
sixth grade um so
good old days and uh
yeah this is round three so i'm 21 25
i'm playing in 1800
and it's black to place we've got a
night end game with equal material
and it's not entirely it's not
immediately transparent who's better
well it kind of is if you know what to
look for you should look for peace
activity who's got the more active
pieces
not a trick question of course it's
black and look at the despair knight on
d4s
tying down white snipe that's great
you've got a weakness he's hanging down
of course it's black the king is good
white's king is good but it's sort of
its power is limited by the fact that i
have a passer on f6
um that is you know potentially going to
be very valuable
but i started to think here i couldn't
find for a long time for the life of me
a plan to win the game you played to win
the game
i didn't see how to break through
because if if i give a check on e2 and
try to get the knight around c1 he
actually starts hunting for my pawns i
didn't want to allow this
black can easily lose this game if you
allow white to take the h7 font that
gets fast
so i wanted to keep the knight on d4 you
could play h6 but
white's gonna just shuffle the king
between e4 and d4 e4 and f4
and then finally i found i had an aha
moment and i found a plan
and fixing the weakness that is the key
to winning this position bingo a4
that is correct where is this pawn going
he goes king e4 boom not only are you
fixing the weakness you're carving
out you're carving out the c3 square but
that square is only meaningful in light
of the fact
that there's a pawn on a2 that is going
to be the weakness which is fixed
and he cannot stop me because of his
passive pieces
uh from getting the knight to c3 winning
the pawn and promoting
literally nothing that he can do about
it he desperately tries to
but i play knight takes c2 i win this
pawn that's not the point though
then i come back to v4 take a2
look at how the king fully limits the
knight
and that was that
and he resigned in this position so it's
as simple as that
if you look at this position initially
you might think it's close to a draw
this is a very powerful endgame plan if
he had tried to go a3
and preempt me then he you know it's the
same concept now the pawn is fixed on a3
you can go knight b5
white is losing i mean this is there's
no defense here you can go b3 check
probably that's the best movement i
think there's no defense i'm not sure
maybe there is
i haven't analyzed this game in a long
time but now you can start collecting
these bonds
okay does that make sense and
is are there any questions okay it looks
like everybody's clear
all right guys i think we've got a lot
of yours but it is time to for me to
call it a day i have to go to sleep
otherwise i will not be coherent
tomorrow
at noon because we are covering with my
partner in crime robert
the uh magnus tour and
that's gonna be a lot of fun i hope to
see you guys there
um i will not be able to commentate
every day i think i'm gonna have to skip
next week and i'll be traveling back to
california visiting family
but i'll be doing it as much as i can
i'll be doing it tomorrow probably on
tuesday
i'll be skipping thursdays so i'll keep
you guys posted
there will be days when robert does the
commentary alone but i will be there
tomorrow at noon eastern
uh on my stream twitch stream and on
robert's twitch stream
uh we will be back together to
commentate the magnus or bringing into
you guys
we'll explain more tomorrow and with
that
let's pause the cameras could somebody
let me know actually let me go to twitch
and see who i can raid
um i'm gonna go full cam here for just a
second
yeah thank you guys for the support
emacs toffee everybody for the
tons of gifted subs and the tons of
support yeah maybe i should write ludwig
should i read ludwig just rub it in a
little bit
let me see i don't see anybody who's
streaming
so we might just have to make it a lot
of a great kind of day
we might just have to oh he's got a 24
hour stream nice
all right let's read ludwig i really
appreciated the fact that he and charlie
made the time
for the event that will go on youtube as
well so let's read ludwig
it's just ludwig right that's his twitch
channel it's just ludwig
it's not it's just ludwig right
yeah it's just vlog okay guys thank you
so much everybody stay safe folks
take care see you tomorrow at 12 raiding
ludwig
bye for now